MIKE: Danielle is
sending us to see Bob.
Apparently his grandson says
he's got a ton of stuff.
MIKE: This dude is
off the beaten track.
FRANK: I know.
I don't even see any signs.
Hey, what's this up here?
A bunch of buildings.
MIKE: This is mega.
FRANK: Let me get a flyer out.
[dog barking]
MIKE: Well, there he is,
right here.
Must be the grandson.
[dog barking]
MIKE: Hey-hey!
Man, you guys are off
the beaten path a little bit.
DAVE: Oh, a little bit.
MIKE: Nice to meet you.
DAVE: Dave; nice to meet you.
FRANK: How're you doing?
DAVE: My grandpa's farm.
He's got, uh...
a little bit of everything
for you guys to look at.
MIKE: Yeah, I see he's got
a lot of stuff outside.
DAVE: Yeah, he doesn't
go anywhere without
bringing back something.
MIKE: No kiddin'.
DAVE: These barns are just
getting fuller by the day.
He has trouble letting
go of some stuff.
FRANK: Sure.
DAVE: Right through here.
MIKE: Hey-hey.
FRANK: Hello.
BOB: Hello.
MIKE: How are you?
BOB: Wonderful.
DAVE: This is my
grandfather, Bob.
MIKE: Hey , Bob.
FRANK: Hey, Bob, I'm Frank.
BOB: Hi, Frank.
FRANK: Nice to meet you, sir.
MIKE: Alright.
So, you were told
we were coming, right?
BOB: I heard someone was coming
that might buy some of my junk.
MIKE: Alright, well,
we buy a lot of junk.
BOB: It's easier for me to
tell you what I don't collect
than what I do collect.
MIKE: Choo!
FRANK: You got a lot
to look at here.
DAVE: We can't go
to a garage sale
without him filling the truck.
MIKE: Can we look
around a little bit?
BOB: You bet.
MIKE: Whoa.
BOB: I can't stand to see
anybody throw anything away.
If I see things selling
ridiculously cheap,
I have to buy it, whether I got
any interest in it or not.
FRANK: So you collected
a little bit of axes and saws
and primitives and tools.
BOB: I now refer
to it as a disease.
FRANK: Bob, what
about this gauge?
BOB: It's for sale.
FRANK: It's for sale.
BOB: Yeah.
FRANK: It's a brass gauge.
Alright, someone has put...
somebody's put a clock
mechanism in the back there...
and turned it into a clock.
BOB: [laughs]
FRANK: 40 bucks.
BOB: You got a deal.
FRANK: Alright, you got it.
MIKE: Bob, there
was something here,
and that was probably signage.
You know, the paper sign
or the cardboard sign
would drop to the top of that.
BOB: I understand.
MIKE: And that would hold that.
45.
BOB: Okay.
MIKE: Alright, I appreciate it.
FRANK: Bob is in the mode
for selling.
He's got over 70,000
articles in here.
He's ready to
get rid of stuff.
FRANK: Hey Bob.
BOB: Yeah.
FRANK: This is
a little box here.
And I found this, this is
a dry chem fire extinguisher.
These two items,
would you sell it?
BOB: Of course.
FRANK: Okay, so 40 on the box.
BOB: Yeah.
FRANK: 20 on the extinguisher?
BOB: Alrighty.
FRANK: Good deal.
BOB: I'm getting
a little long in the tooth.
If this stuff stays here,
the kids will probably end up
selling them for
10 cents on the dollar.
MIKE: Let me see this chair.
Put that on the ground,
let me see if the legs...
FRANK: It's wooden.
MIKE: Yeah, I know.
That's what's
interesting about it.
The backrest part right here...
FRANK: Adjustable.
MIKE: ...is wood.
The bottom of it adjusts too.
FRANK: Oh, I see.
MIKE: Oh, look at that.
Whoa.
You see that, Bob?
BOB: Holy smokes,
the price just went up....
MIKE: [laughs]
BOB: ...about $50.
FRANK: As it went up,
the price went up.
MIKE: 100 bucks.
BOB: Each?
MIKE: No.
[laughs]
[laughter]
FRANK: You know, you
always hope you're gonna
meet great people,
and you also hope
you're gonna meet somebody
that has a great collection.
Well, today, we got both.
[honks horn]
FRANK: See you, Dave!
See you, Bob!